let's be real 2020 has been a year but
it's also given us some memorable
memeable
and momentous celebrity and pop culture
moments this year
a lot of them that brought us joy i'm
danny directo and i am joined by our
very own ash crosston
and melissa johnson ladies what a year
we've had
but let's talk about the happier times
ash
why don't you kick things off for us
what are some of your favorite celebrity
pop culture moments that brought you joy
this year
i want to do the games that kind of
brought us together
so first we had animal crossing which
launched
on march 20th that was kind of like the
beginning of the pandemic
and it quickly became like the biggest
game
in the world the first console game to
reach five million digital sales in a
month
everybody was playing it and a lot of
the credits of that high sales was due
to the covet 19 pandemic but
it was like i mean y'all remember it was
like hard to get a
switch i don't even know if you can
still get one everyone was playing it
celebrities were playing it there was
even like
talk shows made around this game there's
a
writer named gary widow who wrote star
wars rogue one a good screenwriter but
he made like a talk show
where he would have celebrities come on
in the animal crossing game
and he would interview them and brie
larson was on it and just
everyone was playing it everyone it was
like the first way that we could all
visit each other virtually
i mean really it was ahead of its time
in a lot of ways wasn't it
yes and it was a lot like you much
prefer to assume happy hour
yeah here's my question for you though
do you think animal crossing would have
popped up
popped off as much as it did if we
weren't in the middle of a global
pandemic like was it still fun
was it fun for you to play i think yes i
think the people that
grew up at that game were like really
excited for the new version to come out
but i think
it the surge was because of the pandemic
i mean i had people like
texting me slacking me and being like
what is animal crossing should i get
this should i get into this can i beat
tom nook and i'm like
yes because it's the only way we can
hang out right now and you can have pink
hair if you want
i never think this is my first time
honestly hearing about animal crossing i
must be out of the loop
but this is new to me this is definitely
something i'm learning
i wouldn't put it past uh someone out
there in hollywood
writing this animal crossing script
right now like yeah it's a popular video
game but i'm just
predicting that we will get a series or
maybe even a movie
especially because they don't need to
hire real actors so they could do it
from home while we're also on lockdown
uh in the meantime what was another
positive celeb moment
in your world and then my other
feel-good story i just want to mention
because i'm in the gaming mode because
and i played a lot of tony hawk because
they remastered it whatever
um the feel-good story with tony hawk
that went around on tick tock when the
fedex driver
uh a kid gave him a skateboard and said
get this to tony hawk and the fedex
driver was like uh
okay i'll do my best no address nothing
like that
and so he took it to tick-tock to try to
get it to tony hawk and not only did
that happen tony hawk sent him a
skateboard the
the young kid was a six-year-old fan
named cooper and he sent him a
skateboard and it was just so
heartwarming because i love hearing that
celebrities like this are cool
you know i was honored that that cooper
would be so inspired by me that he'd
want me to have his old skateboard
i also feel like you know tony hawk he's
probably
thinking about his own kids too and
there's it's been like a rough time for
a lot of people especially all those
kids who have literally
been cut off from their friends they are
stuck at home all the time and so to
like also
i don't know share a little joy and and
make them a little happy by just saying
what's up and then also
sending them a board i mean you can't
beat it and shout out to the fedex
driver because he did not have to go
through what he did to get that
news out there you know he made a tick
tock specifically for cooper
to get tony hawk's attention so shout
out to him as well
i love it those like essential workers
just doing it right
right they're doing the lord's work
literally really okay so
alicia how do you pick how do you narrow
in on a celebrity or pop culture moment
that made you happy that just made you
smile this year i just think about what
i can recall the quickest
and one of those moments is the rise
of the cuomo brothers and pop culture i
mean they took over especially around
june when andrew cuomo new york governor
andrew cuomo was doing the press
conferences every day
and of course we see chris on cnn every
night they
literally stole america's heart and the
new term
was created homosexual and there's a few
people who
identify as homosexual including jada
pick and smith and chelsea handler
and myself i mean it was so refreshing
it was just really refreshing to see
andrew and chris step up to the plate
this year
as sincere leaders during this pandemic
that plus their attractiveness
and straight talk demeanor just turned a
lot of people into what we see now
as homosexuals and there was merchandise
everywhere
the fascination with them just continued
to grow
and i just look at them as glimmers of
light in this darkness because
we would go to them for news right and
half of the time the news was
really bad but at the same time we
walked away with moments
that just reminded us how important
family is i mean these are brothers
right
and they never shied away from picking
on each other as brothers
either even in the midst of those hard
conversations
so it was just really refreshing to see
this plus their dad
is also the former new york governor
mario cuomo so he passed away but i'm
sure
he would be so proud of the way his sons
handled this pandemic this year
i'm not gonna they're daddies i was just
about to say
what is zaddy's status like i'm not
gonna lie i followed chris on instagram
years ago
uh because you know what he looks good
with his shirt off he shares a lot of
shirtless instagram posts
but then fast forward to this year i
mean you talk about them stepping up to
the plate malicia and it's true
i mean chris himself actually um tested
positive for covet 19
earlier during the pandemic and still
actually broadcast
on cnn from the basement from his
basement where he was
quarantining from his family but then
when you throw in his brother too who of
course is trying to
lead the state of new york through this
pandemic when you get them together on
screen for
those interviews those are some of the
best and most authentic
uh cable news moments during this whole
scary time i was here for it
if you guys had to pick who would you
pick andrew cuomo or chris cuomo
andrew andrew
justice for chris cuomo i know he's a
happily married man but you know what if
i had to choose
my vote would go to chris it's the way
that well it's the way that andrew came
in and just felt like a hero to us
all we wanted him to run for president i
didn't even know if that was possible
but
he was such a breath of fresh air and he
felt like security
during a time that was just so
everything was up in the air
all right mel so what was another
celebrity or who was another celebrity
that um
really did it for you this year okay
tyler perry
you know this has been a tough time
financially for a lot of people
and it's really inspiring to see those
who have the funds
use this time to give back so tyler
perry
this year he continued to wow me with
not only how much he gives to others but
the way he chooses to do it
during this pandemic he left a 21 000
tip to help struggling workers at an
atlanta restaurant
which equaled out to about 500 for each
of the 42 employees
and i mean that could help out with rent
that's groceries for a month that does a
lot
and speaking of groceries he also bought
groceries for elderly customers
at 73 grocery stores in atlanta and his
hometown of new orleans
which was not only great for the
customers in my opinion
but also great for the employees as well
because
they were the ones able to tell these
customers the great news
that their groceries today are free and
the bright spot
the bright spot in this is that it just
speaks to tyler perry's character
is that no one knew it was actually
tyler giving these groceries away
they referred to him as an angel of
atlanta and that just speaks to who he
is as a person
when it comes to giving um it eventually
came out that it was him of course but
at first he didn't want anyone to
necessarily know
and then fast forward to thanksgiving
which we just experienced
he opened up tyler perry studios for
four hours
to feed five thousand families with a
combination of food boxes
and gift cards people were lined up in
their cars
all the way onto the expressway people
slept in their cars
i mean it was beyond necessary and as i
mentioned he just stepped up to the
plate
and these are only a few acts of tyler's
generosity that we know of i'm sure
there are plenty more that
you know we don't know about that's
something me and you denny we talked
about before
he is one of the biggest rags to riches
stories
the entertainment world has ever seen
and he has not lost sight of where he's
come from
and i think because he knows the
struggle so much
he knows what people need who are
struggling and
he just never fails he doesn't he always
comes through with
more than enough well you know someone
who gave us more than enough moments
this past
year brad pitt and let me remind y'all
brad pitt was the king of awards season
and this was before
things really took a turn with this
pandemic people forget
that literally he was collecting every
trophy imaginable
up into the oscars for once upon a time
in hollywood earlier this year but
of course it was his backstage moment
with jennifer aniston at the sag awards
that not only did it happen in 2020 it
set
the internet on fire why was it such a
big deal
well this was the first time the two had
been photographed together since their
divorce in 2005. i feel like we had been
waiting
for an on-camera reunion like this for
so long and then look at this
it's the hand-holding for me yes it's
the physical contact for me
what did you guys what do you remember
about this reunion no for me it's just
it's the body language like the body
language a picture is worth a thousand
words to me this is like brad being like
don't go what have i done
[Laughter]
it's iconic and i just love seeing exes
i could be friends
i mean i want them to be more i'm not
gonna lie but yeah i think you're so
sexy will you come to me do you
sure you know i loved it because this
was a big night for jen
you know she was a big winner at the sag
awards so for your ex to be there and to
also just
show you love at the same time it just
it's just one of those moments for me i
guess i'm being petty betty right now
but just hey you know you see me winning
you just see me growing up i mean brad
he
also had a great year as well but you
know just that moment putting both of
them together in that space
it was a it meant a lot for fans and i
think that speaks to
just how influential they were as a
couple
okay but also it meant a lot to famous
people too famous fans as well i mean
celebs like mindy kaling courtney cox
they were losing their ish over this too
but i think jamie lynn spears said it
best
she said at the time we will be telling
our grandkids about this
and it's true like my brain went when i
saw that this year has taught us
what's really important and just show
love when there's love needed to be
shown
brad and jen did that twice this year
because not only did we get that reunion
backstage at the sag awards
you'll remember they also had a steamy
little table read for the fast times
that ridge
ridgemont hide table read that they did
for charity i mean look at
speaking of body language i mean they
were playing characters and reading from
a script but
man it just gave us such like this
moment right here i
live for it just soak that in for a
little bit but yeah
i got to tell you the other celebrity
moment that really brought me some joy
this year
and this was like i would i want to say
the peak of lockdown at the beginning of
quarantine for us
it's christy tegan going to great
lengths to get some romaine lettuce
because you know everyone was going to
the grocery store
things were flying off the shelves
kristy needed some lettuce
and she was willing to trade someone for
her homemade banana bread
uh and it all started with that tweet
right there you guys
which got the attention of youtuber
chris clemons he responded to her saying
with the photo
i have three studio city holding up a
sealed bag of like fresh
romaine lettuce the best part was the
actual trade-off take a look
yes the deal is about to go down
banana bread two pieces of pie
a bottle of wine all for three
homemade lettuces lettuce
it's about to go down
this is uh this is how i
i think that's gonna happen
[Laughter]
okay send it back send it back okay this
is great chrissy
she was just like us in that moment but
uh ash felicia thank you guys so much
for your amazing picks